I am Sal Segoyan, and thank you so much, Mac for having me back again to be part of your
family and to present. I really appreciate your hospitality and your
kindness and it's a great experience to be here always. Last time I was here I
was talking about the idea of automating the setup of iOS devices using Macs and
I went into detail about how you could set up your own system using Automator
and Apple Configurator. And we covered a lot of detail, and at the very end of
the talk I demonstrated how you could even automate Jamf processes using this
connectivity thing. And it was all about attaching a device and then something
happens. So today I'd like to go to the step beyond what I did previously. I'd
and show you what's new, what's coming up, and why it's there, and why it's important,
and how it came to be. And I think you might find it interesting along the way.
So let's begin. This year has been very tumultuous, a lot of turmoil. Everything
everything seems to be changing. Everything seems to be in flux, not only with the climate,
but in politics, economics, everything seems to be in a transition right now.
And it all really got to me when I saw this picture. How many of you have seen this picture
before? So a good number of you, but a lot haven't seen it. Let me explain a little bit about it.
But it's not a bunch of people waiting for a new iPhone.
This photo was taken by the gentleman down here near Malpurja, and he's a professional
mountain climber.
He climbed six of the world's tallest peaks within one month.
He's an absolutely amazing individual.
But this is on Mount Everest, and this is above 28,000 feet.
This is a line of people waiting to summit Mount Everest. And I looked at
this photo and it just was stunning because I realized that the enormity of
what this is saying. This is at 26,000 feet you enter something that's called
the death zone. And your body, once it hits that altitude, whether you're
breathing oxygen or not, starts eating itself, and it starts preparing to die, and eventually,
if you stay in the Death Zone you will perish. It's just a fact. Humans are not meant to be at
that altitude, and everybody in this photo, in order to be at that point on the mountain with
the sun shining, they had to reach the base camp four, which is above 26,000 feet in the Death
Zone the day before. So these guys have been in the Death Zone for 24 hours. And another thing
to realize is the standard protocol is if you fall down or something happens with your equipment,
everybody walks around you. Because at this altitude, they don't have the energy to be able
to pick you up and to help you. So they go around you. And that's standard procedure. A lot of
people will make the summit but not get down. You're not guaranteed to come back
down once you do get to the summit. So I'm looking at this and I said what in
the world is happening right now that this is what's going on on Mount
Everest? There's got to be some kind of thing happening in the world that this
is what we've gotten to. And it got me thinking about stuff and I have this
formula that was passed to me and I will now pass it on to you and it's a way
that I get perspective on stuff that helps me to understand big picture and
the formula is this insight is gained through the application of perspective
over time and if you look at this for me and you apply this formula you can
understand what's going on. So I said, okay, let me take a look. Let me step back and see what's
happening then. So here we are. We're somewhere right around there under some cloud cover.
And this amazing photo is available to us because of a project from NASA that is the Deep Space
Climate Observatory, and it has a camera called EPIC. And the interesting thing about this
particular satellite, I'll call it, is that in order to get perspective, they've placed it one
million miles away from Earth with the Sun to its back, another 93 million miles to the Sun
so it always sees the earth fully lit by the Sun and it's very interesting that
you know you have that kind of perspective and if you're watching you
can really find out something about it and they have a website this is the URL
for the website and you can go to this website and type in the date that you
want to see what was happening on the earth and so I went to that and I just
grabbed the photos and I put them together to make like this video and I
picked a period this year that was very interesting things were happening in
Europe and I wanted to see if I could understand better what was going on so I
download these pictures and I put them together and I started to realize
that they experienced incredible heat.
They had fires, it was just all over Europe.
There was temperatures above 100 degrees in Paris,
and all of this had followed an incredible winter
where they had freezing like they never had before.
And I started looking at this,
and I started to understand
that there's some change going on, important change.
obvious to see that this change is happening, it's real, and it's causing other things to
affect because we don't live in isolated little vertical columns. Everything we do is related
to each other. Our economies are related to things. The structures of our society, everything
is related together. So I said, okay, well, if that's true, why don't I look at, take this
perspective idea and see how some things that we are affected by have changed over time. And the
first thing I wanted to look at was cars. Now, cars, especially to American, are a very important
things to our lives, right? And they've been around with us since the beginning. Americans are all
about cars. But at first, they were kind of like basic functional boxes that would take you from
A to Z, right? If you were rich, you could have a fancy car. But most people, it was just like a
utilitarian kind of device that would take you from one place to another. And maybe that you had
a sedan with four doors or something so we get to a point where they're selling
these cars and the people that are making these cars and they're going we
need to sell more of these so how do we do that and they started all of a sudden
putting personality into cars cars started developing an image it was an
expression of the real you the inside of you it was who you were and what you
your car started to become an expression of your individuality and then with the
creation of the interstate system we got the open road and they started talking
about the open road the joy of being on the open road where you had the power
and you could ride off into the sunset and the epitome of every American's
dream was to be with their partner riding down the open road and headed off into the sunset.
And that's what it was about. And you would think that with all the changes that we've had now,
with the introduction of electric vehicles that have sensors that can tell all about things that
are around them, they can know where they are, that can be programmed, and they're running on
electricity you'd think that we would be talking about those but when it comes to marketing those
and getting us excited about them we still use the same kind of thing that appeals to us you're going
down the street you're driving over here with somebody else you have no idea who they are and
you go and zigzag back and forth you're headed to San Francisco in the distance and it cuts to the
sky it's still that same kind of approach in reality this is what it is there's San Francisco
And that commercial was, this is Alameda airstrip,
and it was filmed partly over there,
but mostly over there as they're heading off into the distance.
That's the reality of it.
But as another example,
here's Ford with a commercial filmed right across the bay, too.
and this is for the new Steve McQueen bullet a special car designed around that listen to that
how can you not want that it's just like you got it's Steve McQueen for goodness sake you
got to have that car and there it is it's like up the ramp it's headed off to the bridge it's
going to go across the Bay or across to Marin. But in reality, the reality of it is this. And those
who have been to San Francisco know this very well. If you're headed across the Golden Gate Bridge,
you go left. If you're headed to the Bay Bridge, you go right. And it looks like this all the way
up to about 11 o'clock at night. And it lets up until maybe about 3.30 or 4 in the morning.
That's the reality between the image and the reality.
And all of our bridges there now are packed all the time,
like there's the Bay Bridge and there's the Golden Gate Bridge.
And things are getting pretty dense when it comes to cars.
And part of this is because more people are moving there,
but there's also a trend happening in the world,
and it's called urbanization.
and about a third of the population over a hundred year period is moving from the rural areas
to the cities you combine that with just the normal population growth and you start having
this density so it's made people question do i even want to own a car because having a car is
such a pain in this dense urban environment, do I even want to own a car? And that's brought up
the idea of having Uber, and Lyft, and people like that, and taxi services, to try to have them be
your means of transportation. And some enterprising companies thought, well, we'll steal some ideas
from Woody Allen's sleeper movies, and we'll see if we can make, you know, driving gumdrops. And
want to actually be seen in that so they started making them cooler looking right and there have
so the idea of self-driving cars and they're creating fleets of these with the hope that
someday these will be the vehicles that pick people up and intelligently efficiently without
traffic and without accidents somehow managed to get through San Francisco streets and take you
where you need to go. Now, they're already out there. This is the Chevy GM Cruise fleet that
they're using, and they're already out on the roads in San Francisco, and in some locations like this
in Singapore, they're actually in use. So, people are thinking about this whole thing of car
ownership, and it's interesting. What I learned from that was we went from this idea of cars were
of my identity into becoming a service all of a sudden the idea of I needed to
own a car became I don't want to own a car I want to lease a car or have a car
pick me up and that was an important change this was a big change that
happened over time let's take a look at another topic computers now for all of
us in this room, this is the foundation. Whether you started on VAC systems or whatever, you
crazy people out there, you guys, this is spiritually our beginning point, right? We'll all agree on
that. And then over time, we've all experienced all the different iterations of this, and we've
enjoyed each one, and we've enjoyed investing in the company and spending our hard-earned money
and ogling and wishing for each one of those as they came and go,
it can't get any cooler, it can't get any cooler.
Until right now we have this wonderful, very efficient, high-powered feats of engineering
that are the Apple product line.
But along that way, there was another transformation going on as well,
and it had to do with the software that was driving this hardware.
When we started with OS X, and it was a Unix-based operating system,
and it iterated along all this process of hardware,
it stayed as a foundational aspect to enable all of this development.
And even though we're in a new era here with Catalina,
it still is Unix-based.
it might be appropriate to ask how much longer they're gonna allow access to
stuff or things like that but that's a question for another time right now it's
still a Unix operating system for our purposes right so the real important
thing that happened over time wasn't just the hardware a real important event
happened when they released this. That was a foundational change, a paradigm
shift. All of a sudden you had this wonderful device, computer, that was
running Unix that you could carry with you. And it was this wonderful new touch
interface. And this really changed the way how things worked. And with its
cousin the iPad Apple made sure that it integrated with what you had as hardware
and you had this wonderful independent device concept where it was your data
works across all of your devices your data works all across your devices and
isn't it cool you have photos that are are organized for you and it
automatically makes you a video and all of that was meant to make this a
for personal use.
It was your personal device.
You loved each one of them, and they served you well,
and you couldn't wait for the next one.
But at the same time, Apple had a different strategy
that they were executing.
And the strategy that they were going to execute,
they had to do it in plain sight.
And they did it very, very well.
and it began based upon an app architecture where Apple decided to
create an enterprise platform and the things they needed to do were
foundational they they needed a new programming language so they could get
rid of some of the cruft that they had before it's been an ongoing process but
with each iteration, it gets better.
They had to redesign their IDE
and come up with different concepts for that.
They also had to really focus on security,
not just because of personal privacy information,
but because corporations would demand that.
And if you offered corporations security of their data,
they would be attracted to that like moths to a light.
And that's why that became a primary concern.
in addition they really embrace the idea of mobile device management because this
way organizations could manage thousands of devices and if you're going have an
enterprise platform you better provide them with a way to do that and while
you're doing it figure out a way to distribute apps securely and know where
they're going and who's getting them. In addition, document it very well. So this
was Apple's strategy that they started executing while they were telling the
public about the integration with iOS and your Macs and how everything worked.
This is what they were working on and this worked big because they also
partnered at the same time. It's the second part of their strategy was
And Apple did not have the relationships with the different enterprise organizations,
but they had friends who did.
And so Apple started developing relationships with all of these companies,
like GE, that makes incredible turbines, engines, and things like that.
They developed a whole programming architecture based on Apple's tools
that allow their devices to talk to machinery.
Salesforce, a huge presence in the enterprise, has an entire development platform for their
app developers based upon Apple's IDE and Apple's tools.
Same story with IBM.
IBM brought back-end systems like Watson and Cloud to Apple's platform, enterprise platform.
So right there, you have three different companies that are basically betting on Apple's
strategy they're investing in their future and their customers future and embracing apple's
strategy and that's powerful and my favorite is sap i love their logo how everything's like
crammed in there because if you look at this slide it fits their logo this is really dense but if you
actually look in there you'll see that sap is using Apple's enterprise architecture as their
too as well. And you'll also need people to implement. So you go to people like
Deloitte and Accenture to help other companies adopt this kind of strategy. So
you develop these partnerships and even Cisco, you know, gets into the game with
Apple partnering with them. Here's a school in Kansas, Shawnee Heights, where
they developed a secure Wi-Fi system so that the students' data wouldn't leak out or be able to be grabbed by somebody else.
So there's Apple and Cisco working together.
Even Cisco, a networking company, gets in the game of partnership with Apple.
So that's really powerful.
So we've seen that Apple develops an enterprise platform hitting key points that companies require
and then goes and starts partnering with the key players in the enterprise business.
Now, the question is, who are they targeting?
Who are the customers?
And there's a lot.
And all of these are things that we think about and go, oh, yeah, that makes sense.
But we really don't think about the scope of what Apple has done.
And I'd like to just go over some of these.
A couple I'll pay a little bit more attention to than others.
idea of the scope that we're talking about what Apple has accomplished here let's look at aviation
so there's three places in aviation where it's obvious that ios devices are can be really
valuable and contribute one is in the cockpit you know having a flight bag that you've seen
pilots used to carry those things of 40 pounds of paper and they'd be in the cabin before you
you look up there and you could see they're opening binders and swapping out paper and stuff.
You know, that was perfect opportunity for change.
And here's David Clark, who's Flight Operations Manager, and he's talking about an iPad for American.
The first time I used the iPad in flight was the realization and the culmination of about three years of work.
that we thought was possible actually worked out well. The convenience, the
efficiency, obviously the iPad is very light compared to 40 pounds of kit bag.
The ability to update in two or three minutes the content each week and the
ability to move between charts effortlessly, we realized that that this
was going to work well and be well accepted by our pilots. In fact there's
several examples of how this is more efficient than our paper products
previously. For example, if we were to change destination and hypothetically we
wanted to go to Atlanta instead of say a New York destination, I can call all the
charts up for Atlanta that fast. These are all the charts for the Atlanta
Airport immediately available for me. Selection with one touch and there's the
approach chart so perfect example totally logical right if pilots you could fit
everything on an iPad that is handed to the pilot before he goes gets on the
plane you know it has the latest data the latest information that he needs and
it's right there and easy and searchable a second place that iOS devices and
Apple devices can be used is in maintenance and for example here's a gentleman from United
Airlines. The iPad application was developed specifically for United Airlines with input
from technicians across all of UAL's hubs, says Nielsen Pan, Director of Technical Operations.
Basic information that we would usually sit at a computer and do maybe 40 or 50 different
transactions to get that information now is on one click on the iPad itself and all that
right there for you, so it makes the technician's job
so much more easier.
He says new technology also means information
can be passed on in real time,
so technicians are ready even before the aircraft arrives.
So, perfect example, right?
They can use the communication architecture
to talk to the other maintenance guys,
and they can reference materials that they need
for a specific type of plane.
The third place that iOS devices are really useful
of the aviation category, vertical,
is in customer service, of course.
If you have customers, they have problems.
That's just the nature of business.
And you can use these devices
to help solve your customers' problems.
In 2010, we introduced the Mobile Boarding Pass.
We decided we need to do something for our colleagues.
Flight Info is the first app that we released using iOS.
It's a list of all the operating flights for the day.
Previously, colleagues would be given a printout,
and as soon as they left the shift briefing,
that piece of paper was out of date.
So we decided the colleague needs to have the information
about what's going on in the operation in their hand,
so that when a customer speaks to them,
they have the information there and then.
With the Flight Info app, we can actually see on the iPad
the arrival schedule as well as the departure schedule.
to track the other airports around the world that British Airways served.
The next app was for the senior cabin crew member on the aircraft, and it replaced the
paper passenger information list. So the PIL app was developed and deployed. It's been great
because it means that the senior crew member can speak to the customer on a one-to-one
basis.
Having that data at your fingertips in the moment means that you can interpret what needs
to be done right there and then, and that really matters to a customer.
so perfect example of of having all of that data and being able to communicate and maybe make an
alteration to a customer's flight plans or reservations right there in the aisle that's
really impressive and that's why the aviation industry has really become attracted to that
i mean you have all your big players United British Airways just announced 40 000
units that they purchased. United purchased 11,000. Southwest is using them. American,
Singapore, it's become a standard in the industry. And you can't really think about going back to
what it used to be because now it's so much different. It's so much better. It's so much
more improved because they're adopting Apple's strategy. And I saw this the other day because
This was a local Airport up in Washington, D.C., and it blew my mind.
This is Reagan Airport and at Dulles Airport.
You'll notice that they walk up to the iPad.
It checks into the TSA database, does facial recognition, and it's now the new boarding architecture.
So in aviation, there's a lot that can be used.
of devices. Law enforcement is another great example. If there's anybody that
you want to have the most current information about you possible, when
you're dealing with them, it's a law enforcement officer. And law enforcement
is embracing these things as well, and it also provides an opportunity for like
third-party apps. I thought this one was pretty interesting that it translates
translates common phrases the law enforcement officer would use into Spanish, like it can read
their Miranda rights, ask for their license and everything. They just tap it and the phone will
say what they want to say in there. And I thought that was just a great example of a third-party app
supporting law enforcement. This particular picture is from the New York City Police Department,
who recently adopted 36,000 iPhones.
So their officers every day go out on their shift
armed with the latest information
and the latest apps and the latest data,
and they take it with them every day.
So it's not unusual anymore
to see one of New York's finest
and they have an iPhone in their hand.
That's just part of their strategy now.
If you look at retail, of course,
iPads and iPhones make a lot of sense in retail,
Many, many retail companies have their personnel using iOS devices.
It just makes so much sense.
In a related field, food service.
Somebody can use an iPad to input an order,
or now we're training customers to input their own order using an iPad, right?
Or if you do have a point of sale, it's probably just using an iPad architecture.
And some restaurants just went crazy, and they're doing iPads everywhere.
right? And in the hospitality industry, like we're in a hotel, you'll see those all the time.
I've become to see them more and more. When I was recently in Sweden, I stayed at the Riverton
Hotel, which I like because it's on the water. And when I checked in, I checked in through an
iPad at the front desk. And then when I went for a meal, I was handed an iPad Mini that had all of
the information about the food, and I could order right there. It's become some hotels have taken
advantage of the architecture of iOS, and now your phone can actually unlock the door to marry it
through a secure communication, and it'll open the door to your room.
And when you get in your room, there's an iPad that controls all the temperature,
access to all your information, your phone calls, your messages, everything that you need
iPad manufacturing of course you have these huge spaces with a lot of
information carrying an iPad is absolutely essential same thing with
construction I have a friend in San Francisco build skyscrapers the guy
actually builds skyscrapers and he and his team have iPads and they communicate
together and if he wants to look up you know the building schedule on some
rivet of a beam that he's standing right next to, he can do that. That's essential. It's just
become part of the common strategy and part of the common vernacular. And one other area that's
really taken off is healthcare. Because you want doctors and nurses and attending physicians all
to have the information, but you want the patient to have that too. I know I've had my set of
procedures like we all probably have it I had an app like this at the hospital, and I could see the
results of the blood draw that they took 20 minutes ago. I could see what was going on, and that's
really important. At Cedars-Sinai here in Los Angeles, they even use their iPads for newborns
when the mother is in recovery. This way, she can see the baby and talk to the baby, and as a matter
matter of fact, recently, this morning I was having breakfast and the gentleman across
from me was telling me about the hospital that he works at.
Geisinger made a strategic decision to use Apple and iOS devices across the hospital
because it takes friction out of the care process and it improves the experience for
patients.
The screws link the two pieces of bone back together.
The mission was not to just continue the way healthcare had been practiced to date,
but really to think about what's the next way we can take care of patients.
So what we do is we give them iPads so they can be better connected,
better engaged while they're in the hospital.
With MyChart Bedside from Epic, they can check their labs
in a way that's understandable for them,
and we use it to teach patients about their chronic condition.
Before an operating room procedure, particularly for children, we use iPads as distraction
therapy which reduces the amount of sedation and pain medication the patient has to receive
and we know that means that the patient recovers faster.
In the neonatal intensive care unit iPads connect in the mom who may not be physically
present with the baby through FaceTime. This is a time when they're supposed to
be bonding and they're being pulled apart because the baby's sick. That
interaction is huge for the baby and the parents.
Mama's here.
Our purpose is to take care of our patients. You can't do that unless you're
supporting your doctors, your nurses, and other members of the staff. The iOS
platform enables people to do the jobs they're supposed to be doing better.
So is Matthew here? Can I get a mic for Matthew? Matthew, please stand up. This is Matthew. He
works at Geisinger Health Systems, and he's the IT guy there. How many iOS devices are you guys
working with? Right now, it's just over 10,600. 10,000. Wow. That's pretty impressive. Have you
had impact into the kind of care? Oh, yeah. Everybody says it's much quicker. Our doctors
carry them everywhere they go, so they can do their charting and everything right there.
And you're having a good time working with all of the Apple equipment, all the hardware. It's
really solid for you? Most days. Thank you for telling me about your company and allowing me to
put this in there. I appreciate it. Thank you, Matthew. Thanks for using it. Thank you. So,
yeah applause for Matthew so there are some of the verticals there's some of
the customers that are using this Apple strategy that bought into it and we're
seeing another change and transition like we saw with cars going from these
must-have personal devices to services now we're starting to see this whole
concept of these individual devices becoming appliances. Now, appliances is a
weird word when you're talking about computer equipment because you're going,
oh what? What's that? You know, is that a bad thing? No, it's actually quite a
good thing because it allows Apple to have access to all of these different
markets and serve them by creating great tools that change the way that they work
but it's hard to get excited about you know having an iPhone that used to feel
really cool about having and if you had it you could dance on one leg with an
eye with the earphone in or Bono would sing to you if you had a watch or
something you don't think about washers and dryers and appliances the same kind
of way it doesn't take away from the value of what those devices are but just
how they're being used they're being used as appliances and that's okay because what that
means is that Apple is selling a lot of stuff and that means Apple has a good solid future ahead of
them they're just scratching this market now and it means that we can rely on Apple being there
and Apple going to be prosperous and they're going to continue to innovate so it's good that
they have all of these sales and by the way I challenge anybody to find a
picture of an iPad a pallet of iPads I don't think you're ever gonna find I
think they're like hidden they're not allowed to exist or something so this is
the best you're gonna get for that so that means you're gonna have a lot of
large-scale and small-scale deployments you're gonna have some there just a
couple hundred devices or a hundred or fifty or twenty some that are thousands
of devices as he said they had 10,000.
So when you deploy these, there's some challenges.
Some of it can be labor intensive.
You can have procedures that take a lot
to set the device up.
Some of the processes that you have in place
at your company might not be scalable too easily.
And sometimes you have location and network problems.
Like if you're on an aircraft carrier out in the Pacific,
you don't have the kind of network bandwidth
that you're going to do over-the-air Jamf MDM with it, right?
So you have to have a different way of approaching the problem.
Sometimes you need to get large amounts of content on the device quickly,
and that's a challenge as well.
And then you have to maintain the device,
make sure it's always in good operating order.
And then there's the human factor,
because at the end of this all, at the end of every device,
there's a human being using it.
beings have various levels of efficiency and knowledge about particular devices.
Somebody might have inherited a group of devices to manage just because somebody else left
in the company.
Some people are professionals who can manage thousands, some people aren't.
So you have this human factor, and all of that plays into this.
So when we're thinking about how to make this as easy as possible to manage, a consistent
thing that we found is that people respond to the idea of attachment. When you plug something in,
something happens. People understand that. It's a fundamental human principle. Plug it in and then
walk away. And with that, that was what I was talking about last year when I talked about how
to use Automator and Config, CFG Util from Apple Configurator and Automator to
create automation processes that allowed you to access all the different aspects
and set up for iOS devices. And we went over the different strategies about how
you could create a terminal session that did it or you could create a launch
agent that did it. I'm just reviewing the kind of stuff we went over last time and
we created a simple launch agent, and we could have that run the setup
and the automatic execution of workflows just when a device is attached.
It's a localized thing that you store in a system folder, in a launch agent's folder.
And I gave you a special tip on how to create shell scripts that could control this whole process
that you could put in the scripts from available for you. Do you remember that?
In addition, we had a command file that was our bit of magic glue,
basically took the environment variables from the attachment and passed them into
the workflow that it executed and allowed it all to run. And of course we
had an automator workflow that I showed you how to create. And all of that
together enabled the process of attachment. And there was one special
thing where we had an Automator action that would prevent reentry problems
problems because when devices connect, it would create a little stub.
And then during the processing of a device, it will often disconnect itself and then reconnect.
And when it does, it could launch the workflow again, but this little Automator action prevented
that.
And that was our secret, and we also designed it so that it would do load balancing.
So you could handle more than one or two or five different USB devices across that bus at the same time.
And that was basically the strategy.
But now all of that's gone away because we have something called the Apple Provisioning Utility.
Apple, last time I was here, Apple was just starting exploring this.
And now they've modernized this whole architecture.
It's no longer dependent on Apple Configurator.
modern communication. It can transfer data very fast. It's created by the Apple professional
services team, and there's how you can get contact with them if you want to talk about it.
And it's just a phenomenal tool, and it's all based on attachment, and it can handle up to 40
devices per Mac simultaneously. You just plug it into a card of Macs, and it will go to town.
It takes minimal setup. You create an automator workflow, and then you just indicate that that's the workflow you're using.
It has a dashboard interface that you can project to a TV if you want to.
It has no Wi-Fi requirements. All of your network connection can be done through the computer,
which is great if you're concerned about security and you don't want updates or anything happening
where people can get to them in Wi-Fi. It's wonderful for that.
And then it has content caching, so you can have gigabytes of data right there and transfer it onto each device very quickly.
And it has secure and fast data transfer, and it's all on attachment.
Now, with content caching, that's, for the last couple system releases, that's been built into the operating system.
We have a content caching server in the sharing preference pane.
And once it's on, you can choose what kind of content you're going to keep.
You're going to keep system updates, apps, media content,
all of that's possible to keep and store and have transferable to your devices.
And you can set the settings for your cache size.
So on the Mac that's running APU, you set up that,
and then all you have to do is create an automator workflow
because Apple Provisioning Utility has its own set of Automator actions
standard processes that you want to do like erase restore update prepare for device enrollment all
those kind of things are available and you can just create the workflow that you want like this
basic one here that begins with a provisioning you it has a stagger mechanism so that it will
automatically stagger the devices so that they don't overload the bus you can erase the device
update to device, prepare for automated enrollment, and provisioning. And that would be the standard
workflow, like you would run. And in addition, you have all of these other Automator actions,
and you can customize using run shell script action that handles all the standard shells,
and you can have your variables coming in as standard in if you like, or as arguments.
And using that, you can call CFG-Util, and you can have like this one that changes, renames
the device using the device serial number.
Here's an example of removing a specific configuration profile.
Here's one that does the device health tech.
And remember last time at the end of my talk, I showed how you can even execute Jamf attribute
extensions by just connecting the device, and it will change your MDM and change the
just by connecting. So there's a lot of customization that you can do and some
of the standard workflows that APU is used for is like here's one for the
police department device provisioning. This is like their standard workflow
that they would do. And one device, one piece of hardware that's running APU can
provision 120 devices an hour, which is like 960 a day, 4,800 a week, or 19,000 over a month.
So just one unit can have a tremendous impact at a precinct. Here's a workflow for a medical center.
These are kind of the standard workflows that they use. Here's a workflow for a retail health
check on the devices that their salespeople use. All of these are just standard workflows you create
in Automator, and then APU will run them for you.
Let me show you what APU looks like.
So here's the interface.
You have a workflow button, then you have a status button.
It's like yellow if everything's processing,
green if it's completed,
and it will highlight if there's an issue.
Then you can see what percentage of progress is done,
this device serial number,
any kind of feedback about the processing.
In addition, you can see what Automator action's being run, the device name, device type, all
of the version, that kind of information is available, and what slot in your hardware
that device is occupying, and that's important.
So let me actually run one here.
I'm going to pick a workflow, and I have this totally sped up, and it's going to process
10 devices.
normally it takes you can fully process and erase a device usually in anywhere from 10 to 15 minutes
and that means wipe it re-enroll it mdm it copy stuff over to it the whole thing it's pretty
efficient and it's just all based on attachment you don't have to once you've set this to this
station up then you just plug in and that's important because it might be a
nurse that's doing that it might be somebody that you know they clean the
iPad and they put it in the rack and it starts it or it might be a police
officer that comes in from their shift and they take their phone and they stick
it in a rack and the attachment happens automatically for them and starts
processing the device you need to have a common denominator about how you can
use this to set it up it doesn't mean that you can't also use this for if you have a palette of
ios devices and you want to do initial setup and enrollment you can use these apu to do that too
as well and you can work your way through that palette of devices very quickly as well and you
can see that they're becoming green here the one that had the problem that needed to be trusted
is probably the last one up there, and they're independent, so as the employees see that the
green button is there, they can walk up and just take the device away. So that was like 10 different
devices, and it has all of that ability for it. You can project it to a TV screen, so if it's in
the back room of your retail shop, you can just look in and see if you have a green button that
you can get it from. Apple Provisioning Utility is quite impressive. It has a lot of advantages
to it. You can do zero touch, you can do MDM, device health check, all of those features
just by plugging in the device into a piece of hardware. And as long as I'm talking about
the piece of hardware, Bradford has just announced a new type of hardware tray. This particular
in the phone for iPhones. And it can handle like 20 different iPhones. It has a Mac Mini
Mac Mini integration. It has APU controlled LED indicators. So the software in APU can flash the
lights to be whatever it needs. So you don't have to have a screen to look at. You can just look at
the tray and APU can be telling you which device you want to use. And it does simultaneous charging
as well as sync.
It's quite unusual, quite powerful,
and the next step in device management.
It's really impressive.
Now, as far as what the future will bring,
I will note that Macs fit into racks as well.
I'll just make that observation.
So we've seen that the world's in change,
and sometimes you know that whole concept of change can be unnerving but when things are
changing and they're unnerving there is something I always rely on and it's friendship and you can
count that the friendship that you find here at Mac Tech we can solve problems together that we
can't solve by ourselves and it's the friendship that you get here that makes the difference in
the end. Thank you very much.